Олексій Гончаренко європейська
Солідарність як ми бачимо ми стільки
понаприймали з Білорусі що все ніяк не
можемо нарешті цієї окупованою Росією
Україною На жаль і з цим режимом
маріонетковим Лукашенко розірвати всі ці
угоди це треба зробити раз і назавжди бо
ми бачимо як це як цей негідник як в цій
картопляний фюрер вилазить періодично і
щось там гавкає на нашу країну мало того
що звідти до нас летіть смерть мало того
що звідти до нас прийшли вбивати і
різати в Бучі Ірпіні Гостомелі вбивати
українців то ще він до сих пір щось
вилазить розмовляє і розповідає
з'явилася остання його це інтерв'ю Ще
одні зрадниці Діані Панченка До речі в
мене питання де реакція служби безпеки
України де кримінальні справи щодо цих
журналістів і таких як вона які
обслуговували російсь інтереси потім
потім щось клялися В любій Україні ЗСУ
потім Це все повидаляли збіжали знову в
Росію в Донецьк ще кудись і звідти там
обслуговують тепер ворога і окупанта а
далі мають в Україні квартири будинки
чудово живуть деякі працюють і ми бачимо
пенсійних гідність і Панченко вимагає
реакцію служби безпеки на все це а
Лукашенко і хочу сказати Ти негідних
послухай мене Ми тебе знайдемо ми тебе
повісимо на стовпі ми будемо тебе
показувати твоє опудало дітям щоб вони
бачили що відбувається з такими
негідниками як ти який нищить власну
країну ті нищить нашу країну ти за все
будеш відповідати про гаагу можеш тільки
мріяти до Гаги не доживеш